- All right before we roll the credit.
Y'all I wanna share one last
story that might brighten your
day. This is what I'm liking
(upbeat music)
- Philadelphia
- Brothers, eight year old Asil
and 23 year old Dre have teamed
up to write a book that's
helping kids learn to read
and it's all inspired by Asil's
deep passion for reading.
We have these two on the line right now
so every ready let's welcome.
The authors of I can
read so I can lead, Asil
and Dre who watch on the
NBC 10 Philadelphia too.
(audience cheering)
What up, y'all?
- Hello
How did you come up with the idea
of writing a book and
what was the process like?
- Well, when I started
reading at the age of three
and then I turned five
and my mom had a job
at the police district
and I was sitting with my favorite book,
'Green Eggs and Ham'.
And then my mom was sitting
with the other police
officers talking and then
a police officer came up to
me and said, I couldn't read.
And I told him, you couldn't read.
And we went back and forth.
And then I said, and then I read my book.
I proved it to him that I could read.
And he still said, I
couldn't read, jokingly.
And I stood up to him and said,
I can read, so I can lead.
- Oh my gosh, you put him in his place.
(audience cheering)
Dre, how about you?
- So Asil, basically
came to me with the idea
history basically follows
his superpower adventure.
As he teaches his best friend Brielle
how to read and gain
confidence in reading.
And with that being said, you know
the story teaches us that
if we treat each other the
way that we like to be treated
we can all become avid
readers and also role models.
So when Asil introduced
this concept to me, I was
you know, all hands on deck at that point.
So I began illustrating
he began writing it
and it was history from that point on.
- I love this.
So wait, are there more
books in the works?
- Well, yes, I'm having my short story.
My, it's called raining books
and my brother is working
on the illustrations.
- Oh, that's amazing.
I love that y'all are doing this together.
Thank y'all so much Dre and Asil,
this is so cool to do as a family as well.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
- Thank you.
- All right.
Well, that's not all
our season long partner
pilot pin makers of G2.
that go to pin of the Kelly Clarkson show.
Wanna honor ultimate
overachievers, just like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers)
(Kelly chuckles)
(all chuckle)
All right, we love y'all.
Thanks for joining us today guys.